if the courts do not go the right way
if joe biden becomes president is named
president-elect
there is still a lot that we can do in
the meantime you saw a little bit of
this happening yesterday there are
things we can do
with the doj there are things we can do
with the executive agencies there are
things that we can do
as a matter of executive orders so this
came out of the
u.s attorney's office just yesterday
federal law enforcement officials are
investigating hunter biden
for all sorts of tax related matters
shady business deals
that sort of thing there had been an
investigation
already into hunter biden that was going
on because hunter biden
obviously has been peddling his father's
influence
for years and years now enriching
himself to the tune of millions and
millions of dollars
joe biden knew about this we have the
hunter biden laptop
joe biden was aware of this hunter
button admitted in himself that he
talked to his dad about these business
deals
and so joe denies it but we have his son
contradicting him
about it he made a lot of money on this
there was an investigation there
actually was an investigation even
before bill barr took over at the doj
they paused this for the presidential
election because they didn't want it to
be seen as any sort of
impropriety interfering in the election
now that has picked up again
this is very important not because
they're going to nab
hunter biden i don't think they will i
don't think joe biden
if he becomes president will allow them
to nab hunter biden
even though it's so the corruption is so
preposterous
unless hunter biden is some expert in
chinese financial affairs
and an expert in ukrainian energy
companies
obviously this was pure corruption you
had that that ccp expert yesterday
admitting that they bought off the biden
family in china
however the reason it's important is
because if joe biden becomes president
then he's going to have to be the one
to shut down this investigation and
that's
not going to look right he's going to
have to go in there and expose his own
corruption
or allow the investigation to proceed
which
very likely would implicate him as well